hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
generate parentheses so we are given a
pair
a certain number and pairs of
parentheses and we want to write a
function
to generate combinations of all
well-formed
parentheses and so you can see that
these are the examples
and by well-formed they basically mean
like when you're writing code
you know you're nesting parentheses you
want
uh them to be nested in a valid way
right like
we can't have a right parentheses
come before a left parenthesis right
like this
could not be possible we would have to
do it like this
right so you can see for each matching
for each left parenthesis we have a
matching right parenthesis that comes
at some point after it right so like in
the first example
the first three are left parentheses
then the next three
are right parentheses and when they say
n equals three that means we have three
pairs of parentheses so in total
we have six parentheses because a pair
is
two parentheses and three are going to
be open parentheses
and 3 are going to be closed parentheses
right so this is a open parenthesis this
is a closed parenthesis
you can see that when n equals 1 there's
only one possible way to
make them valid because this is one way
and the other way would be this
and we know that this is invalid so how
can we
solve this problem let's just try out
the
backtracking solution kind of right like
a a sort of brute force approach
how would we even do a brute force
approach let's say
n equals three so then we have three
parentheses
what does that tell us about valid
parentheses right like this is one
valid parenthesis that satisfies this
condition right we have three open
parentheses three closing parentheses
well the first thing it tells us is that
we need
three open parentheses and three closing
parentheses right that
much is pretty obvious right like you
could probably figure that out by
yourself
if we have three pairs then we
definitely need three open and three
closing parentheses so in total
six parentheses but what about the order
of parentheses so let's say i have
so far i'm empty right we're empty can i
start out with an open parenthesis
yes i can right but can i start out with
a closing parenthesis
no we know that this is invalid no
matter what i do now
this is always going to mess up our
parentheses
so we can't start with a closing
parenthesis we can only start with an
open parenthesis okay but now let's say
i have one
open parenthesis now what can i do can i
have another
open parenthesis yup because our limit
is
three open parenthesis and so far we
have two so we're allowed to do that
what about a closing parenthesis can i
have a closing parenthesis
yes because so far our open count
is one and the initially the closing
count
is zero and i can by adding this
parentheses
i'm just changing the closing count to
one now right
so now let's look at it now can i add a
another open parenthesis yes i can
because the limit is
three open parenthesis and so far we
only have one
so i'm allowed to add a open parenthesis
what about
a closing parenthesis can i add a
closing parenthesis right now
no because you see that so far we have
one
pair right this pair of open and closing
parentheses and then when you get rid of
that pair then we're just left with a
single closed parenthesis
this closing parenthesis will never have
a matching
open parenthesis on the left of it so we
can't add this parentheses
and how would you figure that out from
code well
just take a look at the count we have so
far before we add
the parentheses we have a count of one
for closed
we have a count of one for open
basically what this
tells us is that we can only add a
closing parenthesis if the count of
closing parentheses
is less than the open count we can only
if
this is true are we allowed to add a
closing parenthesis
so if for example if i were to add
another opening parenthesis
now we update our open count to two
so now we have two open parenthesis
right so two
is open one is closed from over here
right
so now i'm allowed to add a
closing parenthesis right so basically
let's say if we're gonna do backtracking
these are the two rules that we have to
follow
this is basically our base case once we
have three open and three closing
parentheses
then we have a valid uh parenthesis
formation right and this condition tells
us
when we're allowed to add closing
parentheses we can add
as many open parenthesis as we want as
long as it's
under the limit which is n right we can
add up to
three open parentheses but we can
only add a closing parenthesis if the
number of
closing so far is less than the number
of
open parentheses so with that said let's
start
our backtracking solution so we so far
we're empty right
so the first thing we're going to do is
add a open parenthesis so
now this is what we are so far a single
open parenthesis
since we added a open parenthesis that
means the count of
open is greater than the count of close
so now we have two choices
we can add a open parenthesis or we can
add
a closing parenthesis so we have
potentially two open parentheses
or a single open and a single close
okay let's take a look at this decision
here we have
open is greater than or equal to close
right and
the number of open is still less than
three so we can do both
choices so from here we can add another
opening parenthesis so we have
potentially
three and we can add a closing
parenthesis
so two open and one close from
here we see that the open and closed
count is actually
equal right we have one of each so here
we don't have any choices we
have to add a open parenthesis
so what we're going to do is have just
another open parenthesis come after okay
so i'm running out of room but
let's continue so over here now we have
three opening parentheses right so we've
reached our
limit which is n so we can only make one
choice and that's to add a closing
parenthesis so we're now we're going to
have
three open and a single closing
parenthesis
here you can see that we have two open
parentheses
and one closed parenthesis so we can
actually add
we have two choices we can add an open
and we can add a close
so if we add an open we'll end up with
two open
one close and then another open or we'll
end up with
two open parentheses and two closing
parentheses
over here we also have two choices
because we see we have two open
parenthesis
and one closing parenthesis so we have
so
if we add a open parenthesis again we'll
end up with
open close open open
if we add a closing parenthesis we will
end up with
open close open close okay so we're
almost done
start starting over here we see we we
have three open parenthesis so we can
only add a closing parenthesis now so
open open open close close from here we
actually only have one choice even
though we have
more open we have three open and one
close
which open is more than closed so we
should be able to add one of each but we
can't because we know that
three is the limit so we can't add any
more opening parenthesis we can only add
a closing one
so the new parentheses we add is closing
here we also have one choice
even though we only have two open and
too close we know that
the open count is equal to the closing
count so we can't add another
closing parenthesis because that would
make it invalid right
so we can only add a opening parenthesis
so we'll just add a single
open here we all we also only have one
choice because we already have three
opening parentheses so we can only add a
closing parenthesis at this point
here we also have one choice we can only
add a open parenthesis because if we add
a closing parenthesis that would make
this invalid because then
the close count which would be would be
greater than the open count right which
we cannot do
and so at this point for each of these
five we only need to add a single more
parentheses and since this has
three open three and two closed we know
that we need three of each so the only
thing we can do
is add another closing parenthesis to it
right so this is going to be
one possible solution because now we
actually have three of each which is
what we wanted
for this one we have three open and
three
and two closed so lastly we are going to
add another
closing parenthesis and and you might
notice that's what we're going to do for
each of these right because each of
these now has
three open and too close so all we need
to do is add another closing parenthesis
and for this one we also are just adding
a closing parenthesis
and lastly this one we're also adding a
single
closing parentheses so now you if you
look at
all five of these you see that they're
all valid right
and you see they have they have three of
each and they come in a valid ordering
so these
five are going to be returned as our
result these are the five ways we can
make
valid parentheses so now let's finally
write the code
this is basically what we're gonna do
you can see i summarized it so we're
only gonna add an open parenthesis
if open count is less than our input n
we're only going to add a closing
parenthesis if the closed count is less
than
open and we're only going to stop adding
parentheses altogether once our open
count
equals our closed count which is going
to equal n so i'm going to do this
recursively because that's basically the
best way to do it
and i'm going to create a stack which is
going to hold our parentheses
and i'm going to create a variable
result which is going to have
our list of valid parentheses
combinations
and i'm going to do this recursively so
i'm going to put a function
backtrack inside of another function so
if we have this then we don't need to
pass in these two variables
into our function because this is nested
inside of here we also don't need to
pass
n in into this function either but we
are going to have to pass in our open
and closed count so i'll call it open
n and closed n so we know the base case
is if open n is equal to closed n
which is equal to n so in that case we
have
finished and basically our stack will
contain the proper parentheses
so what i'm going to do is basically
some python stuff but you could probably
handle this with a string
if you wanted you don't actually need to
use a stack but i just like doing it
so what i'm going to do is take every
character in
the stack and join them together into a
empty string so
once they have been joined together they
will form a complete string and what i'm
going to do is append that
to our result list and once i've done
that i can just return right because
this is our base case
remember if we want to add a open
parenthesis we have to check that our
open
count is less than n if that's true what
we can do
is to our stack we can append a open
parenthesis
so just an open parenthesis and then we
can recursively continue
our backtrack and but if we do that we
have to increment our open count by one
and the closed count remains the same
and after that backtracking returns
though we do have to update our stack
because we only have a
single stack variable remember we're not
passing this stack into every single
call this stack is basically a global
variable
so every time we're done with
backtracking we're going to pop the
character that we just
added to the stack and if we want to
add a closing parenthesis we have to
make sure that the closed count
is less than the open count so then we
can take our stack and append
a closing parenthesis and then we can
call our backtrack
function our recursive backtrack except
we'll leave
open count the same this time and we'll
actually increment the
closed count and as before we're also
gonna need to clean up so we're gonna
have to update
our stack by popping the character that
we just added
and this is actually the entire function
so you can see we
broke it up into three conditions which
i commented up here
and i explained in the visual
explanation
so the only thing we have to do now is
call our backtrack function
pass in zero for the initial open and
closed count
because our stack is initially empty and
then we can return
what our result will contain which will
be the list of valid parentheses
so as you can see this solution works
and it is pretty efficient
so i hope that this was helpful and if
it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon